Wie geht es Ihnen und Ihrer Frau?
Sie haben beide wenig geschlafen?
Am Ende des Lebens
beginnt ihre Arbeit.
Palliativpflegefachfrau
Livia De Toffol
wird ein krebskrankes Ehepaar
besuchen.
Sie sind beide sehr erschöpft.
Frau Kaufmann
wird stabil schlecht sein.
Sie wird auch mit uns am Tisch
sitzen und erzählen können.
Bei Herrn Kaufmann bin ich unsicher,
wie wir ihn antreffen werden,
denn sein Zustand verschlechtert
sich wirklich jeden Tag.
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Musik *
Frau Kaufmann, guten Tag.
- Grüezi, Frau De Toffol.
Grüezi wohl. Vielen Dank.
Seit 50 Jahren
ist das Ehepaar Kaufmann verheiratet.
Der Krebs wird sie bald trennen.
Ernst Kaufmann hat heute
seiner Frau etwas zu sagen.
Wir haben mal darüber gesprochen,
wie es weitergehen soll. - Mhm.
Ich sagte,
ich hätte mit dir gesprochen.
* Er räuspert sich. *
Mir gehe es nicht mehr so gut.
Du hättest jetzt viel mehr Arbeit.
Auch wenn du sagst, es gehe.
Ich merke es ja selbst:
Dein Atem ... läuft nicht immer.
Aber solange ich renne,
merke ich das gar nicht. - Ja.
Danach bist du kaputt.
Deshalb habe ich gesagt,
dass man eine Lösung suchen sollte.
Ich weiss aber nicht,
wie das gehen würde und so.
Der 74-Jährige will ins Spital.
Zum Sterben.
Es ist
eine Entscheidung der Vernunft.
Trotzdem tut's weh, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Musst nicht.
Sie vermisst das Alte.
Ja, das ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Dass Sie beide
wirklich sehr, sehr gefasst sind.
Was jetzt passiert,
ist normal und darf sein.
Wenn man verliebt ist,
ist man auf Wolke 7.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Wolke
Wolke 17 getauft.
Dort warten wir dann aufeinander.
Ihr Hobby ist das Fertigen
von lebensecht aussehenden Puppen.
Allein bis sie die Haare
aus Mohairwolle eingezogen hat,
braucht sie 100 Std.
Das bringt auch ...
eine gewisse Lebensfreude,
weil man etwas erschaffen hat.
Madeleine Kaufmann
leidet an Brustkrebs, Leberkrebs
und einer schweren Lungenkrankheit.
Für die 74-Jährige kommt eine
Chemotherapie nicht mehr infrage.
Im Zimmer nebenan.
Livia De Toffol hört die
Darmgeräusche von Ernst Kaufmann ab.
Ihre Patienten und Patientinnen
sollen so lange wie möglich
zu Hause bleiben können.
Das ist ihr Ziel.
Doch. Also.
Ich wünsche Ihnen ganz viel Kraft.
- Frau De Toffol. Danke.
Wir hören uns. Ich melde mich am
Montag, in Ordnung? - Ja, ist gut.
Tipptopp.
Ich kann dann auch öfter kommen.
Das können wir
miteinander absprechen. - Gut.
Wir telefonieren am Montag.
- Sehr gut. Adieu, Herr Kaufmann.
Auf Wiedersehen. Danke.
- Bitte schön.
Zwei Wochen später
stirbt Ernst Kaufmann im Spital.
In Livia De Toffols Job braucht es
bewusste Momente des Innehaltens.
Im Büro der Stiftung Palliaviva
gibt es zu diesem Zweck
eine kleine Gedenkstätte
mit den Todesanzeigen
der Patientinnen und Patienten.
Wir blättern immer wieder mal darin
und schauen, wen wir betreut haben,
wer gestorben ist.
Lassen Erinnerungen
durch den Kopf gehen.
Es ist auch ein Moment der Stille
für diese Menschen
und die Beziehung,
die wir mit ihnen hatten.
Dem widmen wir Zeit. Genau.
Der Pflegeberuf
ist ein anspruchsvolles Wechselspiel
zwischen Nähe und Distanz.
Abgrenzung ist wichtig.
Das bedeutet,
dass ich den Leuten
mein Wissen, meine Erfahrung,
mein Handeln gebe
im Rahmen meines Jobs.
Und auch dankbar bin dafür,
dass ich am Abend nach Hause komme
und mein eigenes Leben habe.
Und so auch
immer wieder gut begleiten kann,
indem ich eben nicht mitsterbe.
Jeder Kilometer,
den Livia De Toffol fährt,
wird über Spenden finanziert.
Sie besucht täglich
etwa vier Patienten.
Ihr Auto
ist ein Minispital auf Rädern.
Da ist zuerst mal mein Koffer drin,
mit Verbandsmaterial,
Blutdruckgerät, Sättigungsgerät.
Im Auto selber
haben wir Medikamente,
da haben wir verschiedene Katheter -
für Mundpflege, für ...
... alles mögliche.
Für Interventionen.
Dann haben wir Inkontinenzmaterial -
alles, was wir so brauchen.
Für ihre geschwächten
Patientinnen und Patienten
ist es eine Erleichterung,
wenn die medizinische Versorgung
zu ihnen nach Hause kommt.
(Mann) Welcome.
- Welcome. Grüezi. Hallo, du!
* Der Hund bellt. *
Hoi.
Jean Singgellos
hat Lungenkrebs mit Hirnmetastasen.
Der Musikproduzent
wäre fast gestorben.
... im Unispital.
- Genau.
Letztes Jahr hiess es,
bei mir sei Feierabend.
Ich hätte keine Chance mehr.
Man gab mir zwei Wochen.
Aber ich sagte: "Nein! Ich will
eine Therapie, will mitmachen."
"Ich glaube nicht daran,
dass bei mir Feierabend ist
und ich keine Chance mehr habe."
Und jetzt:
Mit Optimismus, medizinischer ...
Unterstützung und Gott
fühle ich mich jeden Tag
besser und besser und besser.
Livia De Toffol
kontrolliert heute seinen Blutdruck.
Es ist gut. 140/80.
- Wow.
Sie misst die Sauerstoffsättigung
und klebt dem 71-Jährigen
ein neues Morphinpflaster
zur Schmerzlinderung auf.
Alle unheilbar kranken Menschen
haben das Anrecht
auf eine Palliativversorgung.
Die Pflege kann dabei
durchaus Jahre dauern -
wie im Fall von Jean Singgellos.
Er macht eine Immuntherapie
gegen seinen Krebs.
Livia De Toffol
spült seinen Dauerkatheter,
damit es nicht zu Infektionen kommt.
Es darf keine Blutresten mehr
drin haben.
Dem sagt man Stop-and-go.
Flushen, nicht wahr?
So.
Gut.
* Piepen *
Bei der Diagnose Lungenkrebs letztes
Jahr war sein Körper voller Tumore.
Dank der Immuntherapie schöpfen er
und seine Familie nun neue Hoffnung.
Ich glaube,
jetzt habe ich noch 20 Jahre.
Wenn es so weitergeht. Doch, doch.
In Zürich Oerlikon
erwartet sie ein Bürotag.
Von hier aus
organisiert die Stiftung Palliaviva
ihre Rund-um-die-Uhr-Einsätze
für den Grossraum Zürich.
Heute trifft sich das Team
für das monatliche Debriefing.
Hallo zusammen.
Willkommen zur heutigen Supervision.
Trotz vollem Einsatz
kann nur ein Drittel ihrer
Patient/-innen zu Hause sterben.
Das hinterlässt manchmal
Gefühle des Versagens.
Wie könnte man von unserer Seite
noch mehr machen oder unterstützen,
es schaffen,
dass sie die Möglichkeit haben,
bis zum Schluss zu Hause zu sein?
Jemand wollte zu Hause bleiben, und
plötzlich ist er oder sie im Spital.
Was ist da passiert?
Das ist ja häufig unser Alltag: Wir
kommen viel zu spät in Situationen.
Das ist beim Reinkommen
der erste Gedanke: "Zu spät."
Wir hätten
viel mehr erreichen können,
wären wir früher drin gewesen.
Das macht viel aus.
Sterben zu Hause
braucht Vorbereitung.
Für alle ist klar:
Sie möchten mit ihrem Fachwissen
möglichst früh miteinbezogen werden.
Okay, ich würde sagen,
wir schliessen ab für heute.
Vielen Dank
und guten restlichen Nachmittag.
Bis nächsten Monat.
- (Alle) Danke.
Seit dem letzten Besuch bei Kaufmanns
sind drei Wochen vergangen.
Die Welt von Madeleine Kaufmann ist
in dieser Zeit eine andere geworden.
Wie geht's?
- Mir geht's, und Ihnen?
Es geht auch, doch.
- Mein herzliches Beileid.
Danke.
Wollen Sie sich nicht kurz setzen?
- Doch.
So.
Ihr Mann Ernst
verstarb vor einer Woche.
Das Körperliche war nicht wichtig.
- Ja.
Aber das Geistige.
Wir konnten immer über alles reden.
Das fehlt mir manchmal
schon ein wenig.
Das fehlt sehr.
Morgen wird Madeleine Kaufmann
ihren Mann beerdigen.
Zugleich
rückt ihr eigenes Sterben näher.
... diese Leere.
Sie will keine
lebensverlängernden Massnahmen.
Zusammen mit der Pflegefachfrau
hat sie ihre Wünsche
für den medizinischen Notfall
in einer Patientenverfügung
zusammengefasst.
So.
Meine Angst ist eigentlich,
dass man, wenn man hirntot ist,
noch weiter beatmet wird
und weiss nicht was alles.
Das braucht es nicht.
Vielen, vielen Dank
für die Betreuung, auch für mich.
Sehr gern geschehen.
Sehr gern.
- Vielen Dank.
Adieu. - Ich fühlte mich
wirklich gut aufgehoben.
Das freut mich sehr. Und unser Team
ist weiterhin für Sie da. - Prima.
In ihrem Privatleben
sucht die Mutter zweier Teenager
Entschleunigung und Ruhe.
Oft mit Balu.
Der Mischlingshund ist blind, taub
und nicht mehr so schnell
auf den Beinen.
Dies ist sein letzter Sommer -
wie für viele ihrer Patienten.
Loslassen - das kann sie.
Ich selber spüre gar keine Angst vor
dem Sterben, auch nicht vor dem Tod.
Aber auch nicht vor dem Sterben.
Einerseits bin ich im Moment
weit davon entfernt,
andererseits habe ich es
schon so viele Male erlebt.
Und dementsprechend wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so abschreckend erlebt,
dass ich denke, ich müsse Angst
haben. Nein, habe ich nicht.
Seit 20 Jahren schaut sie dem Tod
in seine vielen Gesichter.
Wir besuchen heute Frau Lang.
Sie hat ein metastasierendes Leiden.
Ein Krebsleiden.
Und das schon seit ...
fast einem Jahr.
Der Wunsch von Frau Lang ist es,
so lange wie möglich
eine gute Lebensqualität zu haben.
Die 49-jährige Patientin
ist unheilbar krebskrank.
Grüezi, Frau Lang.
- Grüezi.
Guten Morgen, Grüezi.
Entschuldigung.
Die Mutter zweier Kinder
hat Darmkrebs.
Noor Lang ist schon
seit einem Jahr in Chemotherapie.
So, Frau Lang. Ist wieder ...
- Sie können sich hinsetzen.
Danke, da komme ich sehr gern.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute?
Heute geht es etwas besser
als vor zwei Tagen. - Ja.
Zwei Tage lang war ich ...
Mir war übel,
ich musste immer erbrechen.
Ist es Ihnen recht, wenn ich mal
auf die Pumpe schaue? - Ja, sicher.
Die Pflegefachfrau
hängt die Chemo ab.
Die ist leer.
- Mhm.
Ganz leer.
Noor Lang ist froh,
muss sie zum Abhängen des Medikaments
nicht ins Spital. Sie ist müde.
Ihr Darmkrebs hat Ableger
auf Leber und Lunge gemacht.
Jetzt sind Sie sie wieder los.
- Schön. Jetzt bin ich froh.
Das glaube ich, ja.
Befreit. - Ja,
das ist wirklich eine Befreiung.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
- Ja. Ja.
Ihr Leben ist klein geworden.
Aber Noor Lang beklagt sich nicht.
Was für sie jetzt zählt,
ist ihre Familie.
Sie beruhigen mich so.
Wenn die Kinder und mein Mann ...
wirklich ...
... eine gute Atmosphäre haben
im Haus ...
... bin ich schon glücklich.
* Livia De Toffol packt den Koffer. *
Grüezi, Frau Kaufmann.
- Grüss Gott.
Grüezi wohl.
Seit dem letzten Besuch
bei Madeleine Kaufmann
sind fünf Wochen vergangen.
Ich habe Sie
fast ein wenig vermisst.
Ich habe viel an Sie gedacht.
Es ist doch schön, das zu hören.
Wenn die Kinder kommen, wollen sie,
dass ich in den Rollstuhl sitze.
Dann geht es für sie
etwas schneller.
Und es ist auch bequem,
im Rollstuhl zu sitzen.
Ihre erwachsenen Kinder möchten
für sie nun eine Haushaltshilfe.
Eigentlich
habe ich nicht das Gefühl,
dass ich einmal pro Woche
jemanden brauche.
Es wird ja nicht so dreckig,
wenn ich alleine bin.
Deshalb finde ich, dass
einmal in der Woche reichen würde.
Na ja ...
- Sodass Sie ...
Ich dachte,
so alle 14 Tage würde auch reichen.
Hilfe anzunehmen
ist sicher nicht Ihre Stärke, oder?
Ist das richtig?
- Ja ... Ja.
Bis jetzt konnte ich mich eigentlich
immer gut durchwursteln.
Ja.
Durchwursteln geht nicht mehr.
Sie ist schwach geworden.
Seit dem Frühling hat
Madeleine Kaufmann 30 kg verloren.
Ihr Körper ist voller Tumore:
in der Brust, auf der Leber.
Sie denkt an ihren Mann, der
vor Kurzem an Krebs gestorben ist.
Ich weiss, dass er auf mich wartet.
Und das gibt Ihnen ...
- Ja.
... auch Kraft.
Aber ich kann das
nicht beeinflussen.
Ich muss halt auch warten,
bis es so weit ist.
Ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
guten Nachmittag, Frau Kaufmann.
Adieu, gute Zeit. - Danke
gleichfalls, und vielen Dank.
Sehr gern. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Adieu. Danke, tipptopp.
Jetzt gehen wir zu Frau Albrecht.
Sie ist eine Patientin, die
ein chronisches Lungenleiden hat,
eine COPD,
und die wir schon länger besuchen
und betreuen.
Die Liebe hat Marja Albrecht
als junge Frau
von Finnland in die Schweiz gebracht.
Heute ist sie Witwe.
Wegen ihres Lungenleidens
braucht sie Tag und Nacht Sauerstoff.
Ihr Leben hängt an einem Schlauch.
Was gibt Ihnen die Kraft,
Frau Albrecht?
Dass Sie das ...
... so in Ruhe und auch in Würde
immer wieder tragen?
V.a. die Familie.
Sie gibt einem diese Kraft.
Und v.a. die Enkelkinder.
Die sind einfach ...
Sie geben immer ...
... immer so,
dass man denkt: "Ou ja."
Man möchte trotzdem
noch ein bisschen ...
... ein bisschen da sein.
Es beruhigt die 69-Jährige,
dass sie im medizinischen Notfall
Tag und Nacht die Dienste der Palli-
ativspitex in Anspruch nehmen kann.
110/70.
Das gibt mir
wirklich viel Sicherheit.
Das ist für mich ...
... wahnsinnige Sicherheit.
Livia De Toffol fährt zu den
Hinterbliebenen eines 62-Jährigen.
Daheim sterben geht nur,
wenn die Familie das trägt.
Mich hat sehr beeindruckt:
diese Nähe, die sie hatten.
Untereinander als Paar,
aber auch zu dritt als Familie.
Und dass sie
es miteinander durchgestanden haben,
den Wunsch von Herrn Zeller
auszuführen,
nämlich bis zum Schluss
zu Hause bleiben zu dürfen.
Die 18-jährige Suleika Zeller
zeigt die Todesanzeige.
Das hast du gemacht?
- Ja.
Armin Zeller starb vor fünf Monaten
qualvoll an Leberkrebs.
Vor ein paar Tagen
habe ich auf Papis Handy
Sprachaufnahmen von ihm gesucht.
Ich habe eine gehört.
Als ich ihn lachen hörte,
musste ich weinen.
Weil ich das ... Es ist ...
... das, was ich am meisten
vermisse: sein Lachen.
Er fragte uns, ob das
für uns stimme, auch für Suleika.
Ob es in Ordnung sei,
wenn er zu Hause sterbe.
Wir sprachen darüber.
Das finde ich schon wichtig.
Man ist dann
doch noch in dieser Wohnung
und es gibt noch viele Dinge,
die ... uns an ihn erinnern.
Deshalb fand ich es wichtig,
dass er das mit uns angeschaut hat.
Es war gut,
dass er hier sterben konnte.
Weil es sonst für mich
moralisch nicht aufgegangen wäre.
Ich hätte mir ein
mega schlechtes Gewissen gemacht,
wenn er meinetwegen, weil ich
es nicht hätte aushalten können,
im Krankenhaus hätte sterben müssen.
Natürlich berührt es mich,
dass ich Trauer sehe und wahrnehme.
Das gehört auch dazu
und ist ganz normal.
Aber ihr seid doch beide ...
... den Umständen entsprechend
gut unterwegs.
Es ist Mitte August.
Auf dem Friedhof in Dübendorf
besucht Madeleine Kaufmann
mit ihrer Schwägerin
das Grab ihres Mannes.
Der Krebs hat sie aufgezehrt.
(Schwer atmend) Aber es ist schön
mit dem Brunnen, nicht? - Schön, ja.
Irgendwie
beruhigt er einen ein wenig.
Ja. Es ist sehr schön.
Sie denkt an ihr eigenes Sterben.
Ihren letzten Wunsch
traut sie sich kaum zu äussern.
Es wäre schon fast vermessen zu sa-
gen: dass mir jemand die Hand hält.
Denn das ist dann vielleicht
für diese Person ein Zwang.
Aber ...
Dass man einfach
in einem hellen Zimmer ...
... die Augen
für immer schliessen kann.
Das wünsche ich mir eigentlich.
Zwei Wochen später halten ihr
die Kinder beim Sterben die Hand.
Ihre Asche kommt hierher zurück.
Es ist Herbst geworden.
Livia De Toffol pflückt
in ihrem Garten die letzten Feigen.
Niemand wisse,
was im Sterben auf ihn zukomme.
Was ich erlebe, ist ...
... dass diejenigen,
die früh genug angefangen haben,
sich mit der Krankheit und
dem Sterben auseinanderzusetzen -
v.a. damit, dass wir endlich sind -,
dass die ruhiger gehen.
Das ist wirklich so.
Sie hat Hunderten Menschen dabei
geholfen, vom Leben loszulassen.
Ich finde es immer wieder
erstaunlich, wie wir Menschen
und die Menschen,
die ich begleite ...
... Lebenskünstler sind und immer
wieder versuchen, uns anzupassen.
Immer wieder versuchen, uns
an eine neue Situation anzupassen,
an neues Leid,
auch an neue Defizite,
an immer weniger, das man kann und
darf, das einen vorher ausmachte.
Dass man immer mehr verliert
und trotzdem
immer wieder einen Weg findet,
um ... damit klarzukommen,
einerseits,
und andererseits
dabei sogar auch ...
... eine Art Glück leben zu können.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Meret Gregoris - 2019